[Music]  my  i used to be a grumpy butler always  alone with the team he became my bell  emo by friend of me love remains  [Music]  is  [Music]  us too  when you're finally through your godface  [Music]  [Applause]  there is so much i know about you i kind  of stopped you all day i remain team  edward but now on tv  [Music]  my glasses get so  [Music]  oh  [Music]  i've seen the way you act around  catwoman  it doesn't take a genius level intellect  to see you're not tapping that  i mean damn  look at her  i would flood gotham just to hear that  girl fart through a walkie-talkie  but i know you've been saving yourself  for this  [Music]  is  [Music]  and if you keep turning me down  i might let the clown  [Music]  [Laughter]  whoa that's the stuff so do you think we  should make more of these let us know  what movie you think deserves an honest  theme song next in the comments below  you